moi la première fois je me suis fait
[ __ ]
gpat quand j'ai voté hollande je pense
et
j'espère y parle de la pole je les prie
donc plus vraiment
et celle dont on va parler maintenant
[Musique]
blanche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé qu'ils arrêtent avec ses têtes de
chien battu là moi je vais une attitude
de goûteuses moi je voir briller des
flammes dans tes petits yeux de taupe
ouais
tu me rends c'est la coutume et
l'ostéo qui m'a dit que je ne savais pas
inspiré
quand on dit ça à 42 ans tu peux
considérer que la foire est avis
il faut respirer un bon au [ __ ]
c'était ça les deux trous [ __ ] produit
dit aux gens qui n'a pas d'enfant les
gens te disent toujours tu verras quand
on aura non je verrai peut-être pas il
faut arrêter nous dire ça c'est ça qui
est déprimant c'est cette sensation
d'être dans la salle d'attenté de la
vraie vie donc t'as pas fait d'enfants
il m'est arrivé un truc très désagréable
n'ya pas longtemps c'était pendant ma
dernière coloscopie ou en fait tout le
monde voit ce que c'est qu'une
coloscopie
pour les gens qui savent pas ça c'est un
examen pour lequel on t'envoie une
caméra dans la nuit
et quand on voit on t'envoie pas ce
match
j'ai fait des analyses de selles ont
enfin pas moi à tout va alors que ce
qu'on a là
j'ai donné mes selles
à des professionnels que deux
delas
ldc l'opal j'ai passé du temps récemment
sur twitter j'avais jamais vraiment
passé du temps sur twitter je suis un
moment qu'il faut que vous quand même
voir comment ça marche et je me mets un
soir 20h devant twitter à 4 heures du
matin j'étais encore jeune bien envoyé
snoopy 93 hu mais les gens sont en
danger vraiment l'ordinateur c'était
censé nous faire gagner du temps
dorénavant je crois que c'est clair pour
tout le monde les producteurs n'ont plus
le droit de violer les actrices
est par contre il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas clair et qu'il va falloir
clarifier je pense assez vite c est ce
que nous on a encore le droit fil de
coucher pour avoir les rôles
[Musique]
m
vous pouvez passer ça tout de suite
qu'est ce que je vais vous dise non non
je pense à vous sans succès et est alors
si je vais vous faire chanter je vais
pas l'effacer
s'il vous plaît on est en train de
tourner vous êtes dans le cadre
[ __ ] mais merde vous voyez paquet
caméra là c'est pas vrai c'est assez
dingue les gens suivent ces papous sont
refaites oui qui s'appelle comme dans
toute chose l'enfant
ouais l'enfant dormait le prénom non non
il n'a pas traîné maintenant je vais pas
coller une étiquette sur le premier la
naissance
car les collèges etc ou les féministes
j'adore j'adore ces nanas bravo
c'est un peuple
[Musique]
il paraît que c'est sûr mais son méchant
aussi d'ailleurs mais bon
coûte rien de le dire
je pense savoir que je suis pas
quelqu'un de très j'ai pas quelqu'un
très bienveillant un mois je sais
vraiment j'ai vraiment la première
pensée que j'ai le matin c'est rarement
une pensée tourné vers les autres
vraiment je pense que ça m'est jamais
arrivé de ma vie même de me réveiller un
matin et je me dira
j'espère que les autres vont bien merci
de m'avoir écouté merci bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]